uh let's bring you some breaking news
the reported merger we've been telling
you about between the struggling banking
at Giant credit Swiss and UBS so let's
go live to our city editor Mark Kleinman
who joins us on the line morning to Mark
what's the latest yeah This concerns the
global banking sector's most significant
merger since 2008. I understand this
morning that British Watchdogs have now
given their blessing to a takeover of
Credit Suisse by its Swiss peer UBS as
Financial Regulators around the world
race to contain the industry's biggest
crisis in 15 years or so and our sources
have told me and my colleague Conway
this morning but the bank of England has
indicated to its International
counterparts and to both companies that
it will support the emergency
transaction the two Banks want to
announce a deal later today although key
details remain uh unclear at this stage
her Credit Service of course has been
brought to brink of financial Calamity
despite securing a 54 billion dollar
credit line from the Swiss Central Bank
several days ago and this move was
designed to reassure markets and
depositors but it failed to Halt a rush
a customer withdrawals uh prompting a
request from the Swiss government for
UBS to explore a takeover of its rival
late last week now Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor and Andrew Bailey the bank of
England Governor are being kept informed
about about developments because
although credit Swiss has a market
valuation of just eight billion dollars
now fears for its future sent shockwaves
through financial markets across the
world as I say Credit Suisse and UBS
working towards announcing a deal as
soon as this evening before markets open
in Asia on Monday in the hope of
averting further contagion in the global
banking sector
all right Mark good to hear from you
thank you very much indeed Mark climbing
there